We've decided to make a new video about aluminum because it's a long
time over five years since we made the first one.
And we didn't say very much,
It's a surprisingly abundant element.
If you look at this periodic table here where the
area of the different elements gives you a rough idea of
the abundance,
you can see that Allie minium is one of the most abundant metals up there with
sodium magnesium and calcium,
more aluminum than potassium, about the same,
or perhaps even more than the iron. We're never going to run out of value.
Minium.
The problem with aluminum is that you don't find aluminum metal
in nature as a metal. It's always tied up with other compounds,
mostly with oxygen in clays. You know,
what plays are the sort of muddy stuff that you get stuck on your shoes when
it's raining to get the aluminum out of the clay that
is to break the aluminum oxygen bonds, which are very strong,
requires a lot of energy, which comes from electricity.
So making aluminum is very energy
intensive.
That's why people like to recycle aluminum because once you've got it,
it's worth preserving,
but it's fantastically important because aluminum is a very light metal.
And it's often used as an alloy because the
aluminum alloys are stronger than the aluminum itself.
So if you're using it for, um,
aircraft or some other use like that,
where you want to combine lightness with strength,
then the stronger you can make it the better.
But when it was first made in the 19th century, isolates as a metal,
it was terrifically valuable.
And there are stories of the French emperor serving his honored guests
with Alli minium plates or aluminum cutlery,
while the less important people had silver or gold,
but those times have passed.
And now you can get cupcakes and things like that,
surrounded by foil of Valley minium,
Allie minium is a very good metal for making things because it has a very thin
coating of aluminium oxide on the surface,
which prevents it reacting with things. But as soon as that coating goes,
it becomes very reactive.
[Inaudible]
Oh,
I guess we're standing by for your high gain alignment for the checklist.
I may have seen a video where we put copper chloride in one of these
cupcake holders. First of all,
I'm going to dissolve some up and make a fairly concentrated solution.
I need to place this here.
And what came out was this,
or rather the copper chloride came out through the hole.
It starts boiling really quite nicely.
Now imagine I was doing this for my children who were quite small at that
time and Bush and the aluminum was
completely dissolved up forming aluminum chloride and copper
metal in my own research.
Aluminium is quite important. Quite a lot of our equipment uses aluminum,
not so much for the high pressure tubing that we use because quite a lot of
my research involves high pressures,
but we use it for the metal blocks that we put round the tubing so that we can
heat it up. Aluminum has a good electrical conductivity,
and it's also easy to machine.
This is a piece of equipment here where we have a
tube going down the middle. You can see the diameter of the tube here round.
It is an aluminum block and an electrical
heater. Now this particular case,
there was an accident or a mishap because the
thermocouple that was controlling, the temperature of this fell out.
So the heater got hotter and hotter and eventually the
aluminum melted and pull down here.
And I think this is really beautiful.
Well, fortunately I was not in the lab,
but I would have got very angry with my students. But I think when it happened,
it was quite exciting. This would have been glowing,
almost red because the melting point of aluminum is around 500
degrees centigrade, but then once it formed originally,
it was very shiny,
but quickly to get developed the surface layer of aluminum oxide.
If you have fine particles of aluminum and blow them into a
flame,
then they will burn quite spectacularly.
And you form aluminum oxide. Now on the face of it,
Allie monoxide sounds a rather boring compound,
but it's really very useful.
And we use it quite a lot in our research in all sorts of different ways.
It looks like a white powder, not very exciting,
but in our group,
this aluminum oxide has been a fantastic catalyst,
all sorts of reactions that we didn't expect have gone with this material.
My students keep it in the bottle, almost like a magic catalyst.
And I've only been given a little to show you,
it acts as a solid acid,
which can be used a very high temperature and we'll get various acid
catalyzed reactions of organic compounds. It will make ethers.
We have made various alkenes and a whole series of different compounds.
And my students still use it very much.
If you melt the aluminum oxide, which we can't do here,
but can be done industrially. You can make single crystals,
which are transparent like glass.
And then you can grow a single crystal tube like this one,
which, because it's a single crystal is terrifically strong.
It's the defects that make something weak.
And so if you have just one crystal there no defects.
And so it's very strong.
So you can put a very high pressure inside this tube without blowing up.
You could make that tube out of metal processor.
But if you have metal, then you can't see what's going on inside.
And we are using these tubes for photochemical reactions.
So we take a light like this and
shine it on the chemicals, going through the tube and the high pressure.
And we can convert one chemical into another.
We can do this very efficiently because the light is absorbed by the molecules
that we want to react.
And so we don't waste the energy on everything else and using LEDs,
which are very efficient, light source.
You can get a process that is very energy efficient,
and it all depends on having the Safa tube.
This is synthetic Sapphire,
the real Safa,
the chems have impurities in them of other metals,
which give them the nice colors. Particularly the blue princess.
Kate has a blue Sapphire ring,
which belonged to her husband's mother princess die before her.
And so these are very valuable ones,
but synthetic Safa is also expensive,
but not in the same class as a natural gem.
What can nature do that? The guys at the sofa factory can.
Nature has time.
The people who growing this will take hours or days,
or perhaps weeks to grow it nature can spend thousands of
millions of years growing a particular gym,
and therefore they can heat it up and cool it down in
natural surroundings in volcano or whatever far
more slowly than people can afford to do industrially.
There's a lot of argument, whether you should call it aluminum or aluminum.
Now there isn't totally correct.
One because both forms are acceptable,
but all or nearly all chemists use minium because it's
very important to use a standardized nomenclature right across the
world. And I think aluminum sounds nicer.
My question is, is it aluminum or Allah minium?
Cause I wouldn't know what to call my Alinea model.
Apparently there was a decision in 1990 by our,
you pack the instant national union in the pure and applied chemistry.
The teacher would definitely be called Allie minium,
but then they relented three years later and said,
you could use aluminum as well. But if you're a serious chemist,
you really need to say Allie minium because otherwise people won't
find your papers,
your publications when they search,
because they almost certainly put an eye in the name
Minium is frequently used or used frequently to be used for.
So spins for cooking because it's easy to make easy to
machine. And particularly when people used electric stoves,
it was easy to make a flat bottom so that you've got good contact between the
electric element and the saucepan.
The problem with aluminum saucepans is that if you're cooking some fairly
acid food, for example, boiling lemons or rhubarb,
something like that, which is quite acidic,
you can dissolve some of the aluminum and people got quite worried
about getting aluminum in their food. Also,
if you cook red cabbage,
which is an indicator blue for alkali red for acid,
then if you boil it in a Allie minium saucepan,
it goes blue. And earlier in my career,
I used a red cabbage to get with the white one,
to make a union Jack,
a UK flag with a mixture of red and blue,
red cabbage and the white from the white cabbage.
Unfortunately I've lost the photo. Brady is very cross with me,
but it was quite fun cooking it in the kitchen. I did it once myself,
but it was such a lot of work that the second time I got one of my students to
do it.